hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and skincare nerd
so recently the channel asap science released
a video called the only face cream that works
according to science a lot of people sent this
to me asking me to do a response so here it is
if you like nerding out about the science behind
beauty products then click the like the subscribe
and the notification bell so you don't miss any
videos so the idea of the video is that there
are lots and lots of misleading myths in skincare
marketing the video is loosely based off the aging
skin chapter of monty lyman's book the remarkable
life of skin it's actually really exciting for me
to do a response to a video that's made by science
nerds because usually it's something like five
minute crafts so we're going to dig into some of
the more interesting issues about science and skin
care so it's unsurprising that since asap science
is a science channel and the book is by a doctor
not a dermatologist but still a doctor most of
the messages in the video are largely correct
there is tons of misinformation in the skincare
industry and lots of brands are just trying to
sell you hopes and dreams in the form of
products that cannot possibly work like
they say in the video the terms dermatologically
tested clinically proven and active ingredients
do not mean much at all and a lot of the bs
around skin care is indeed because the skin
is actually an excellent barrier this goes
both ways so really potentially useful active
ingredients can't really get through the skin very
easily to where they need to be to actually work
on the other hand it also means that potentially
harmful ingredients find it really hard to get
through your skin into your bloodstream and so a
lot of that fearmongering is bs but there are a
few myths and misconceptions that i think came up
in the video which i'm going to talk through now
firstly you can't tell if something will
work just by looking at the ingredients list
so the premise of the main part of the
video is that greg who doesn't use skincare
is showing different products to mitch who
does use skin care and mitch has to decide
based on the ingredients list which product is
better so which one has a better effect on skin
the problem is you can't tell just by looking
at an ingredients list whether or not a product
is going to work it tells you what ingredients
are in the product so you can tell if it could
potentially do what it's claiming to do but
that's about it there are some other really
important things that you need to know to work out
if a product will actually work first there's the
dose the ingredients list usually doesn't tell you
what the concentration of the active ingredient is
you need a minimum amount to work and in
general there's a dose-response relationship
the more of an ingredient you have
generally the better the response is
up to a certain point generally if you go too high
then the benefits start to level off but the side
effects will increase and at some point the side
effects just aren't worth the benefits anymore
i talk about this concept a bit more in my video
on why the ordinary's 100% powders aren't a good
idea even if you look at the relative positions of
ingredients that still doesn't tell you very much
at one point mitch picks a cream with glycerin
as the third ingredient over another cream that
has glycerin as the sixth ingredient in most
countries the ingredients list is ordered so
that the thing you have at the top is the thing
you have the most of and it goes down from there
down to about one percent but apart from that
there's still a lot of wiggle room so you can
definitely have a product where the third
ingredient is at a lower concentration than
in another product where it's the sixth ingredient
the ingredients list also doesn't tell you much
about the delivery system in other words if the
other ingredients in the product are made so
that it helps the active ingredient get into the
skin where it needs to be to work in medicinal
chemistry we call this pharmacokinetics you can
sometimes tell a little bit so sometimes you can
see a penetration enhancer in the ingredients list
but you don't know if there's enough in there to
work especially given all the other things in the
product you also can't tell if the ingredients are
arranged into an effective delivery system or if
they're just mashed up in there getting stuff to
go through skin is a whole area of pharmacology
there are tons of textbooks written on it
it's really complex and the ingredients
list just doesn't tell the whole story
so then we go into looking for active ingredients
in different products and working out whether or
not they work and the conclusion is that only
retinoids will work so here's where i think
definitions are really important basically
the definition used in this video is that
there has to be a scientific consensus that the
ingredient can get through skin to the dermis and
increase collagen to decrease wrinkles i think
there are a few problems with this definition
firstly losing collagen isn't the only reason
that wrinkles form there's also the loss of other
substances in skin like glycosaminoglycans changes
in the types of collagen and elastin in the dermis
and thickening and dehydration of the stratum
corneum and wrinkles aren't the only thing that
people care about in skin care there are tons of
other reasons people use skin care products things
like acne fading pigment and treating dry skin
even if we stick to anti-aging wrinkles aren't
the only thing that happen it's one of the things
that gets talked about the most but in dermatology
there are lots of other aspects to anti-aging this
is especially the case in people who aren't white
where pigment changes are a much bigger issue than
wrinkles so these are things like uneven pigment
age spots and sunspots ingredients also don't
need to make it to the dermis to work again if
we look at all of the other reasons that people
use skin care we have things like moisturizers
moisturizers work mostly on the top layers of
the skin the so-called dead stratum corneum they
smooth it out and increase the water content and
this can actually reduce the depth of wrinkles
and even though moisturizing seems like it
might have a really surface level minor effect
it can actually have a pretty big impact in one
study on patients with atopic dermatitis they
found that petroleum jelly this mostly just sits
on the surface of the skin and seals in water this
actually increased the production of antimicrobial
peptides thickened the stratum corneum and changed
the way that skin cells developed even with
something like silicone sheeting this is literally
where you get a silicone sticker and stick it on
your skin this can change the structure of scars
that are quite old and it mostly does this just
by keeping the scar hydrated and there are quite
a few skincare ingredients that work well enough
to be classified as drugs and these generally
don't have to make it to the dermis dimethicone is
classified as a skin protectant benzoyl peroxide
is a really good anti-acne drug that mostly works
on the acne bacteria on the surface of the skin
and in pores we also have sunscreen which just
forms a layer on the top of your skin to protect
you from uv rays and that's enough for it to
be legally classified as an anti-aging drug in
australia now onto the scientific consensus
there are a few issues with this as well
so for things that go into your dermis and change
how it functions skin care products aren't really
meant to do this they are classified as cosmetics
if it actually did that it should really be a drug
so i'm going to paraphrase the US's food drug and
cosmetics act to the things that are relevant to
skin care a drug would be something that treats
the disease or affects the structure or function
of skin a cosmetic would be something that
cleanses beautifies or changes the appearance
of skin most countries have a similar definition
one really frustrating thing about this definition
is that it doesn't really reflect the reality
of what happens when you put stuff on skin
if you put water on your skin it will change
how well your skin conducts electricity so
a function but we would never classify water as
a drug so it's usually the intended effect of a
skin care product how it comes across in labeling
or marketing that determines whether we classify
it as a drug or a cosmetic so when a company gets
fined for breaking this regulation usually it's
because their product makes drug-like claims not
because their product acts like a drug so saying
that a product reduces wrinkles is a drug claim
but rewording that to reducing the appearance
of wrinkles makes it a cosmetic even though it's
the same product in different packaging the big
difference for a company between a drug and a
cosmetic is how the product would be regulated
it's a lot easier and cheaper to sell a product
as a cosmetic drugs have to go through years of
testing for safety and effectiveness before
launching onto the market and this can take
millions of dollars a cosmetic product
doesn't actually need any official approval
so if customers are going to buy it anyway there's
not much incentive to go through all of these
loopholes to make it a drug so we're in this weird
regulatory situation where there are a lot of skin
care products that definitely do more than a
cosmetic should there are all sorts of studies
that support the fact that it'll change the
function of skin but no one really wants to say it
out loud some countries have tried to get around
this by adding an extra category so cosmeceuticals
or quasi drugs this is the case in japan but
in most western countries this hasn't happened
so that means the only ingredients where there's
a strong scientific consensus that it works like
a drug are ingredients that are classified as
drugs a product can't actually claim that it
reduces pigment even if there's pretty darn good
studies showing that it does and even if it's been
classified as a quasi-drug in japan which means
that their government is pretty satisfied that
it works this way in a drug-like way so because of
the very narrow definition here of the word work
that means that only vitamin a derivatives or
retinoids really fall into this category but even
then there's still a bit of extra complexity there
are a range of different retinoid ingredients and
not all of them work the same way and they don't
have the same level of evidence behind them and
so we can't really treat them all as one big
category not all retinoids are regulated as
drugs and the ones that asap science actually talk
about in their video which are retinyl palmitate
and retinol aren't actually classified as drugs
retinol is one of the ingredients that most people
in skincare including me recognize has a lot of
evidence behind it and it's actually approved
as a wrinkle-reducing quasi-drug in japan but to
work it has to be absorbed into skin and converted
via two steps into tretinoin which is actually
regulated as a drug retinyl palmitate needs an
extra step for this and so that's even less well
supported there's also the issue that just having
retinol in a product doesn't mean that it works
for drug products the final formula has to be
tested to work on people's skin but for non-drug
ingredients like retinol the final formula hasn't
necessarily been tested it isn't something that
you can see on the ingredients list and so there's
no guarantee that it'll work all you know from
the ingredients list is that at some point they
chucked in some retinol it might not get into the
dermis it might not get very much through skin
it might not go through skin at all there might
not even be any retinol in the product by the
time you get it retinol is pretty unstable
and so there's a decent possibility that it
would have all decomposed by the time you get
the product so just seeing the word retinol on
the ingredients list doesn't mean you have a
product that definitely works so now I'm going
to go through some of the other ingredients
that asap science talked about in their video
the first product comparison is with a collagen
cream and Greg says that anything with collagen
is 100% bs I pretty much agree with this collagen
is pretty overrated but I would probably downgrade
that rating to about 90% bs collagen is in a
lot of products and is definitely mostly in
there to tell a good story as Greg points out
collagen is too big to get through your skin
there's no evidence that any delivery system is in
the product to help that collagen get through skin
and even if it gets in there who knows what it
does you do have collagen inside your skin and
losing collagen is linked to more wrinkles
and thinning skin but just chucking collagen
in there might not do anything at all it's like
how sprinkling hair on a bald patch isn't going
to make it hairier or at least not in the
right way but collagen is actually a pretty
good humectant moisturizer just like glycerin
which Greg mentions in the competing product
humectants are ingredients that are really good
at grabbing onto water and keeping it on your skin
so your skin gets smoother and more flexible and
more hydrated and humectants will have this effect
even on the surface of your skin it's actually
the top few layers of the stratum corneum that
go dry and flaky so big chunky collagen still
works even though it can't get down very far
so the next ingredient is vitamin c they
talk about antioxidants and creams and how
there isn't really a scientific consensus there
and they look at two different creams and they
say that the one with two forms of vitamin e is
better than the one with one form of vitamin c
the problem here is a bit like the
problem with the retinoid discussion
not all antioxidants are the same different
antioxidants have different antioxidant abilities
some of them are more powerful than others
they also have different distributions once
they go into your skin so vitamin e is oil soluble
which means it works mostly in the cell membranes
vitamin c is water-soluble so tends to work in
the more watery areas like the inside of the cell
different antioxidants also have different
molecular sizes and different polarities which
means they have different penetration into
the skin so just look at all of these dudes
bigger ones generally don't make it as deep as
the littler ones they also have different levels
of evidence to support them and I have another
video where I talk about which antioxidants have
the most support vitamin c is actually one of the
ingredients that has a bit more data to support it
it's not only an antioxidant it also has other
properties and in Japan it's actually regulated
as an anti-pigmentation quasi-drug pigment
fading is more of a priority in east Asian
skin aging than wrinkles there's also evidence
that in some skin care products it can get
into skin and increase collagen there are some
clinical trials where volunteers put vitamin c
on one side of their face and not the other then
they took biopsies of both sides these are like
little chunks of skin that they cut out then the
collagen in the dermis on both sides was measured
and there was more in the vitamin c side there's
some evidence that vitamin e can fade pigment but
not to the same level as vitamin c and there's
nothing convincing on vitamin e and collagen
one group of ingredients that asap science does
recommend alongside retinol and antioxidants
is palmitoyl polypeptides if you're
using all three then you're checking
all the boxes for any scientific
sort of understanding for anti-aging
I think if you're a skincare nerd you'll also
have been quite confused by this recommendation
pulmonal polypeptides and peptides in general
don't really have that much evidence to back
them up there are a lot of ingredients in between
retinoids and palmitoyl polypeptides when it comes
to evidence of them working you have niacinamide
alpha hydroxy acids arbutin hydroquinone
so the reason I think they included palmitoyl
polypeptides is that in Monty Lyman's book
he highlights synthetic peptides as a
really interesting and rapidly evolving area
I don't think he meant to imply that there was
more research on these than the other ingredients
that he mentioned in passing just that it's
an area that might be good to look out for
he also talks about a clinical trial that was done
on a boots No 7 cream this trial is actually quite
impressive because it went on for 12 months
most cosmetic products don't have this sort
of length of trial the big problem is that the
list of potential anti-aging actives in this
is here it's impossible to work out which of
these ingredients actually worked in the trial
and again palmitoyl polypeptides are a really
diverse group they all have palmitic acid
connected to a string of amino acids but what
the amino acids actually are is really important
you can't just stick any amino acids together
and hope that it works they have to be a specific
sequence that your skin can recognize and of
course with all of these different types of
peptides there's different levels of evidence
for each one so I think I'm going to stop there
for this video there were a few other things I
picked up but I think I'll just leave them in
the comments let me know what you thought of that
video and the points I brought up here click the
like if you liked the video subscribe you can also
follow me on Instagram at @labmuffinbeautyscience
and check out my blog if you like more nerdy
beauty content let me know if you have any
other videos or pieces of content that you want
me to deconstruct and I'll see you next time